[Music]
2019 New York comic-con we're back
Startalk
all right we're gonna do some comic-con
stuff tonight I promise you that this
theme for this evening is the science of
pop fiction and we have two scientists
myself included and from the start talks
table of experts we have our resident
geek in chief I'll introduce him in just
a moment but first let me get my clothes
Chuck nice Chuck come on out here love
you man let me do that all right Chuck
nice go take a seat and next up we have
a friend and colleague he's an
astrophysicist at the CUNY system based
in Staten Island come on up Charles Lou
Charles was that about I'm just so
excited to be a comic-con New York
comic-con is the best it really really
is yeah all right
comic-con rocks man so so we've got
three segments the first one will be
devoted to the topic of fictional
elements that even mean
well Mike antimony arsenic and blue M&M
selenium the hydrogen oxygen nitrogen
and rhenium those are real elements oh
yeah we talk about fictional elements
win anything so what role do fictional
elements play in the world of comics
fundamentally of course there are only a
certain number of elements like eating
if you count the ones that we have been
able to create in the laboratory 100
hundred twenty hundred and twenty
something right but we always finish
everything in the universe is made of
one hundred and twenty things right yeah
but we always have to have something
that makes someone be able to fly or
stretch or run really fast so it's got
to be an element of some kind right
really they're compounds most likely
there might be a Lloyd's they might be
metals but don't worry elements are good
but in the comic books think generally
whatever they are they're not common
they're rare yes and they have special
properties like I said that they want
that's usually they're strong in some
kind of way yes okay so one of the early
one of these is Thor's hammer how you
pronounce that you have to say it like
you're taking a dump is that part of it
I'd rather like to think of it as the
Norse Norwegian stately godlike
Asgardian oh now that was convenient so
it's an Asgardian dump okay okay so who
is a fictional element they don't have a
lot of and what about Simon Asgard
Wolverines claws
what are those adamantium antium another
element and Wonder Woman's bracelets
feminine
feminum feminine okay that sounds
malformed because elements should end
and I um except for aluminum all the
others are I um feminism that should be
FEM Minear well maybe if you're in
Britain right cuz you pronounce them
aluminium so this is feminine iam Ezreal
on this welfare many amounts so much
better than what to call feminine
feminine feminine there from Paradise
Island what do they care how we
pronounce it true I'm just saying you
know feminine sounds like something that
you would use to you know get rid of
like male toxicity you know we decide
ladies is your man in a hall
well the feminine so would be like a
perfume you could either spray it on or
give it to him in a pill you know and I
mean try new feminine well the term
feminum came originally from a two-part
episode called The Feminine Mystique in
the original Wonder Woman television
series of 1976 and 1977 damn featuring a
young 20 year-old Debra Winger
three-time Academy Award nominee as
Wonder Girl wonderful sila yes Diana
Prince's fictional younger teenage
sister well Academy Award or Emmy Award
nominee she was nominated for three
Academy Awards Lynda Carter regrettably
has not yet been nominated for an
awesome man let me tell you something if
I didn't know and love you as much as I
do I would think you would have an
unhealthy obsession with Wonder Woman
given what he knows about guilty as
charged
also so tell me more about the bracelets
what okay theoretically the bracelets
were originally a symbol from the
ancient Greek days this is based on the
Wonder Woman sort of creation anthology
back in the 1930s and 40s she's Amazon
yeah she's Amazon but these bracelets
were a symbol that they were subservient
to men that they had been captured by
men they were enslaved by men but what
happened was when Paradise Island was a
and broke free Aphrodite the goddess of
love made them indestructible and a
symbol of the great abilities and powers
of women specifically those Amazons on
Amazon so turn it back I back on it's on
its head that's right
right and so what happened was that now
they are bulletproof and they were able
to deflect bullets and if you're skilled
enough you can block weaponry and so
forth and the pilot of the original
Wonder Woman TV series which I still
can't find on reruns anymore if any of
you have a copy let me know where I can
get one there's a scene where she is
trying to make money because money was
not something she was used to and she
got on a stage and she was knocking away
bullets people were shooting with hand
and there's some little old lady brings
out like a tommy gun like a submachine
gun and starts blasting I can't find it
anymore
a little old lady is trying to kill
Wonder Woman yes the Tommy what they
submachine gun yeah
what the hell what the episode was at
the pilot the first two-hour series one
yeah and you wonder why they bought it
please I mean I would have been the
first lady
yes picked up a tommy gun to kill Wonder
Woman well not so much to kill but yes
to kill she she was a Nazi agent and the
whole point was that she's a Nazi
grandma remember that the original
Wonder Woman series was set in right or
to historical fiction so what happened
was that this character okay
Wonder Woman Lynda Carter needed to make
money and so she was a stage personality
a impresario like spider on stage right
so that she could like demonstrate
people paid tickets bought bought
tickets paid money so that she could
stop bracelets and have them watch it
and then some old lady came up said I'd
like to try and she came up and she had
a you know violin case and she opens it
up and it's a before you know and it was
like well we do this and and and then
she's oh he can't do that signal and
then one woman says she's not afraid oh
right and she goes up and I still can't
find it
good they're all that's you because I
don't know what would become of you if
you found that I have a bit of physics
observation to share that only came to
me in this moment
oh yeah it's not good enough for the
bracelets to be bulletproof you have to
be faster than the bullet to put the
bracelet in the way of the bullet to
block it right if you're that fast you
could just step a step to the side yes
right yes I'm just thinking there there
are two good reasons that you know well
first you kill Pluto really why stand in
the middle go sweet you'll pull a matrix
thing on it and do one of these there
are two good reasons not to dodge
although you can do that yes one is that
you protect the people behind you but
not the people on the side and that was
the second point just like in but see
the Phantom Menace it was right when it
was first introduced that you could use
your lightsaber to deflect blaster shots
and use them as weapons against the
people that are firing against you one
by and I'll use those bracelets to
attack in defense of the Jedi when they
use a lightsaber
they don't just deflect it they send it
back to where it came from
thereby rendering the shooter Wonder
Woman is that what he just said will you
paying attention 14 seconds ago I have a
very sort of - but and one other bit of
physics about blocking bullets handguns
wouldn't but a rifle shot is actually
supersonic typically so if it's the
bullets moving supersonically your hands
would have to be moving supersonic Lee
as well to intersect them typically so
so each hand would leave a little sonic
boom behind and so and that they didn't
do that so well they missed an
opportunity that's true yeah real
science all but also keep sure they're
losing sleep
right we gotta move on Chuck Charles
tell people why metals are generally
strong things because so many of these
fictional elements are metals of some
kind that's true so what is going on
inside the atom and whatever lattice
it's in that makes them strong relative
to rocks or anything else well that's a
complicated question of course right
almonds easy it's the answer you're
saying it's complicated so good right
easy question real science makes it very
hard right metals are essentially you
think of them as many many atoms that
together work together to form like one
atomic like structure that's why for
example they conduct electricity really
well they do those kinds of things in
general but within metals
there's a lot of variation right and
that's why alloys are very important so
for example copper and tin are both very
soft if you actually hat in a tin foil
right we use aluminum these days but
copper and tin are very soft but if you
can smelt them together then you create
bronze which is actually very hard and
so the whole concept of the Bronze Age
right where for more than a millennium
of human history it the fates of entire
civilizations and cultures were
determined by whether or not you could
get tin and copper together to make
bronze was all about whether or not you
pneumatology well enough and the
Hittites were very important also in
smelting iron metallurgy
yeah metallurgy metallurgy metallurgy
okay oh I see where we're going with
this okay I'm just trying to I didn't
know what you said so I have to like
translate it yeah metallic metallurgy
metallurgy metallurgy like I said yeah I
stand corrected
okay Metallica
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay so so tell me about an Iron Man
he's got oh no he's got palladium in
there what is that okay all right there
could be some very serious Iron Man fans
out there yes it did not like that react
see and together now no no it Iran is
cool I have no problem with Iron Man
it's the Palladium part okay okay you
see complain him is one of the elements
on the periodic wires a little bit of
history okay back in the 1960s when Iron
Man was first created the suit acted
like a defibrillator or a heart helper
because he had that shrapnel in his
heart so it was none this arc whatever
right but actually he occasionally would
actually have to sit down in some room
and plug in his armor chest plate like
into the wall in order forget to get
recharged enough to keep his heart
beating
that is awesome yeah that was in the 60s
in the 80s Marvel Universe this is based
on the Marvel Handbook of the 1980s
officially his armor was solar-powered
he actually had perfected an industrial
strategy where you could put like little
mini microbes sized solar panel chips
into the armor which allowed him to
charge from the Sun and allowed him to
have a super power that way
that's brilliant yeah it was really cool
right but now there's palladium and the
reason that came about was in 1989 two
scientists in America claimed based on
their experiments that they had
developed cold fusion through palladium
you remember this Neil I remember and
the stock price went through the right
it did palladium futures went crazy but
what happened was they were trying to do
these what we now call just so cold
fusion normal fusion takes millions of
degrees to slam nuclei together which
are positively charged you want to
overcome their electrical repulsion
because positive rejects positive right
they opposites attract but positive that
the sames repelled so right if you can
do this on a tabletop without requiring
a million degrees then you can produce
energy but not having anything start out
to be hot at all well the claim was
palladium was one of
these ingredients like that's right hans
bethe in the 1930s who won the Nobel
Prize for this figured out that you
could do nuclear fusion when he got so
hot not because it was so hot that it
could overcome the electromagnetic
pulsing but you could create the
environment for something called a
quantum tunneling reaction that would
allow two protons to come together and
become a deuterium nucleus now what
happened was that the I think sucker
wrote bonzai he tunnels through the
mountain doesn't it in his car yeah do
we agree on that yes yes yes absolutely
yeah but what happened was it the
Palladium folks thought that they could
create this quantum tunneling effect in
palladium at room temperature okay we're
close to room temperature instead of
having to go to millions of degrees and
so they thought they did it sort of
palladium 107 becomes palladium 103 plus
a helium 4 plus a little bit of extra
energy or something for the next five
years huge amounts of time and energy
and money were invested in trying to
reproduce that experiment and it never
worked so finally by the mid 90s people
decided that this really wasn't
mainstream this was just an unfortunate
or an accident or something that they
did these two dudes own I do not know
but the answer is there are still plenty
of people in the world today who think
that there might still be something to
that cold fusion thing nowadays we call
that low-energy fusion reactions or
something lef our research and so that's
why palladium still holds a little bit
of interest in the sort of fictional
world of trying to create power
something from nothing so so let's go
straight to particle accelerators if you
want to make them if you're gonna make
an element that you don't happen to have
handy so what do we do we take an atom
and we bombard it with lots and lots of
neutrons okay and in the proper
circumstance one of those neutrons will
stick or a few of them will stick and
then you create an environment where the
new element is born because neutrons
will transform into protons through
specific processes having to do with the
weak nuclear force alright so and so
basically in Princeton we can make any
any element we want so the whole dream
of alchemy
is real today it is absolutely real is
just not economical yeah right we could
make gold out of lead but it's cheaper
to to go buy it at the corner gold shop
and right yes and I will mention that to
this day
astronomers we think that the best
manufacturing of elements comes from
stars when for example a star goes
supernova the elements surrounding it
are bombarded with so many neutrons
sometimes thousands of neutrons per
second that there are possibly quantum
tunneling reactions that can happen that
will create elements with atomic numbers
in the 150s even in the 200s only they
don't stay around in our universe for
very long they decay almost immediately
so let's go on to Thor's hammer guru
okay again he's still constipated yes
without hammer huh so I just want to say
that when I saw the Thor movie the one
that has Natalie Portman playing an
astrophysicist you say that like you're
angry about it no no I just letting
people know that my people my profession
shows up in movies I'm just saying
right on really there was an
astrophysicist in Top Gun Kelly McGillis
Telemachus was an astrophysicist I don't
know why because she was an expert in
the f-14 planes well none of us are but
she was an astrophysics I'm just saying
but you know a listen danger zone a
Nicholas Cage was an astrophysicist in
the movie knowing in the movie knowing
okay it really should have been called
not knowing actually if you saw the plot
but but so we out there so anyone I'm
watching the movie and I'm thinking I
wonder how heavy the hammer is and
there's a scene where his father talks
about about linear in the name of the
hammer right and says that there it is
forged in the heart of a dying star
listen I got this it's made it a dying
star we we know dying stopway
astrophysics people so I went home
densities of the densest dying Tsar so I
got a pulsar dense packed with neutrons
and I said I'm gonna make Thor's hammer
out of neutrons so I got a replica of
his hammer measured the volume figured
out how many neutrons you could fit in
it and then I tweeted how much that
hammer would weigh and I said if Thor's
hammer is made of neutron star material
as implied by legend it would weigh the
equivalent of a herd of 300 million
elephants yeah and and that's all know
if you take the hammer like that and you
dropped it it would fall through the
earth as if it were not there cut all
the way through the center of the earth
come out the other side and then come
back and oscillate back and forth
ripping out the interior guts of the
earth as we rotated it would not be cool
so then you must know that what I'm
about to say is true wherever you think
you are in the geek spectrum wherever
you well if you think you're at the top
there is someone at comic-con who knows
more about it than you do okay no matter
who you are it is like a semi infinite
continuum of expertise and that's why I
love comic-con with Larry six hours yes
just a terrific place within 36 hours
someone tweeted back okay dr. Tyson you
were wrong about Thor's hammer its 356
million and so I was apparently really
wrong really wrong
yes so apparently they cited a Marvel
Comics trading card from the 1990s that
said Milner is made out of fictional
material guru and it weighs exactly 6.2
pounds
[Laughter]
6.2 pounds and so I'm saying I like my
answer better yeah but your hammer you
can't use it to actually do anything
well accept me more quick good well I'm
not done wait so so okay so I mentioned
this one time it had a like a super fan
in the front row and it said 6.2 founds
did they say on which planet it weighs
six point two
[Applause]
yes we are not working you can find the
planet where the 6.2 hammer weighs 300
billion elephants and then hgtv tweeted
is it a ball-peen hammer or is it
[Laughter]
just saying what can you build so here's
the problem I thought it was made out of
neutron star material okay but that's
not what he said in the movie he said
it's made in a neutron star in the in
the field of a dying star and then they
capture that in the Infinity the guy
that's right infinity words that's the
whole contraption right there you go
they use the power of the neutron star
to forge the yeah so let me end this
first segment tell us about vibranium
vibranium yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
vibranium was introduced in Fantastic
Four number 52 which came out no this is
the wrong audience to make that stuff
that is so true yeah alright it's a
thing okay go 52 I own Fantastic Four
number 52 that's why I know what does it
do it's a beat-up gold copy it smells
all more what if I this is gamma Con
okay this is Comic Con don't you share
the love of a beat-up old 1965 comic
book
thank you hey telly tell me about the
properties of vibranium originally when
it was designed vibranium was just able
to absorb any kinetic energy in other
words it just magically dissipated so
any impact on vibranium made it as if it
were never there that made it like
Kevlar
yes but better okay I mean so good right
and in fact the Super Society of Wakanda
which again was introduced in this time
in 1965 I mean Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
were so ahead of their time right this
super society in the middle of arc
Africa but but at that time the black
panther was not spiritual in the
sensitive now that he has like the
powers of the ancestors and so forth he
was just so well trained right and so
smart that he was a superhero and he had
great technology and he was really
talented that way but he had problems
with this guy named Irving Klaw who had
killed his father in a much more elegant
way than they was done in the movies
while though was okay in the movies too
I guess
am i right that the movie Black Panther
had two hobbits in it hobbits yeah you
mean from middle-earth yeah I might
think I'm right there I missed them yes
okay the actors who played hobbits
[Laughter]
that's different okay they're taking the
hobbits to Isengard am so vibranium
later on was actually mixed into Captain
America's shield from the 1980s so it
was a mixture an alloy of vibranium and
adamantium which made it even stronger
than pure adamantium which is what
Wolverines claws are made of an Ultron's
body etc as you well know so modern
modern vibranium as done in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right at the very
beginning it's claimed as the world's
hardest metal right the world's
strongest metal it turns out that the
strength of it is completely secondary
to this amazing ability for it to absorb
kinetic energy that's what made it
special so vibranium is cool but it was
not because it's hard but because it's
literally soft power the ability to take
whatever it gets and be able to spread
it out and produce this both marvelous
technology and also incredible weapons
of war but what if that in a black man I
don't know what is right so so it
doesn't only absorb it it keeps the
energy and you can do things with that
energetic playback oh evidence to the
movie energy storage device yes ok very
cool is there anything on earth that we
know of that actually can mimic that in
some way in any way the storage battery
yes that can take that's all we with
that can take kinetic energy turn it
into potential energy and then put it
back out yeah yeah rubber ball
right you know what man you ain't have
to be a hole about you know I'm just
saying I'm gonna end the first segment
on the a-hole comment you are
participating in star talk live New York
I'm God
[Applause]
we are back New York comic-con 2019
Chuck nice co-host thank you sir leading
at Chuck nice comet Chuck nice calm
excellent a Charles Liu hello do you
tweet that Chuck lu CH uck I'll try you
so you're both Chuck's well yeah but
he's the real Chuck no no no we're both
jocks
yes yes we're like two chucks
okay that's how many Joseph I was gonna
do it in a second you know but this is
how many Chuck's it takes to chuck that
would sir all right so let's talk about
how you get around the universe
God talk about how you get around the
universe and the technologies that
empowered it so we've got obviously the
warp drive oh yeah
and so just just to put some reference
frame here if in Star Trek they did not
have warp drives and they were
constrained to just the speeds that we
currently achieve with our fastest
Rockets these are the ones that don't
even have people on right the fastest
Rockets it would take them a hundred
thousand years to get from our solar
system to the nearest star system about
a hundred thousand years which greatly
exceeds the life expectancy of human
physiology unless you travel almost the
speed of light in which case everyone
else would die but you'd be just fine so
that's enough time so start date so what
is 4372 everyone on earth is dead
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how is it that in the series he's 50
years old but had the body of a 25 year
old speaks with a British accent but had
a French name what's that what is that
that is the beauty of jean-luc baby no
no today we would call that cultural
appropriation no no if you do it
respectfully and if everybody is
together in peace and harmony like they
are in the 24th century
I don't consider appropriate okay that's
a that's a fourth century we'll find out
yeah what is war what is going on what
drive in a warp speed most of you in
there probably know better than we do
but basically the dilithium crystals
create a reaction through the warp
nacelles which creates a warp bubble
which allows the object within the
bubble to travel through what's called
subspace which is a sort of a higher
dimensional construct let our spacetime
lives in allowing us to travel from one
point in our space to another point in
our space faster than light would be
able to travel that same speed but
you're not really traveling faster than
light you're within this little warp
shell that's the authenticity
authenticity the science of Star Trek
right yes the only problem is of course
then you have to be able to communicate
in subspace sub saves communications
presumably if you're sending a radio
signal that's traveling at the speed of
light and if you're traveling faster
than the speed of light you get there
before heuchera tells you there are
Klingons on the starboard bow that
doesn't work so well so they had to
create this subspace communication thing
too that would get there faster than
they've mastered right so there's less
you beat the signal and what good is
that exactly so that's not talked about
very much but it's a big no it's not a
trap okay so how would you contrast Star
Trek faster than light travel to star
wars vessel oh yeah making you do that
you're not Bo on okay
Star Wars one is number one the other is
number two
maybe number seven the situation with
Star Wars travel right the the overall
Star Wars Lightspeed jumps and so forth
unfortunately there's a lot of
inconsistency in how Star Wars moves
from place to place
you think Star Trek purposefully made
this warp bubble thing to make things as
causally reasonable as possible for Star
Wars I think they just punted it's
really hard to imagine a way where you
can for example fire a planet killer for
example in one solar system to send it
all the way to another solar system
instantaneously pass a third solar
system as you're watching it go by in
the sky and then destroy five planets in
a fourth solar system right it's just I
mean how are you getting there that's
fact people complain when I talk about
movies that way oh yeah I mean I'm sorry
and and look we are not even gonna talk
about the Kessel run okay don't get me
started not hold me back even gonna talk
about the Kessel run they make a mistake
calling time a distance and then they
double down on it in sequels Wow okay
the coastal run in 30 part how many
perhaps around 12 parsecs
oh my god really are under 12 so is 11
points under under 12 under 12 are 12
hundred 12 parsecs which is a unit of
distance yes I'm angry that let's skip
this no I'm not even gonna I'm old
enough because I'm older than both y'all
two remember seeing Star Wars in
first-run episode one which became
episode four yes when he jumped to
Lightspeed that was freaking awesome
yeah no one had done that and you had
the blur of the stars like whoa and then
when the first Star Trek movie came out
then they just copied that because they
didn't do that in the series that's
right okay oh they did better than that
they wound up with the wormhole just a
visual effect so I give him that's a
very good note the only other scientific
fact I'm gonna give Star Wars what
the Luke sees the double sunset because
we know astrophysically that more than
half the stars you see in the night sky
contain at least two stars in orbit
around each other
neuroticism some are triple star systems
some are even more and that was never
portrayed in fiction but you know the
problem with tattooing double star
system if you take the geometry of the
sunset and where those stars were the
temperature that they probably do good
Tatooine and so forth and you watch the
planetary orbit and what a bad orbit
would have been unstable yeah tell you
something it's so funny when I was
watching that scene I thought the way
that's sustainable gravity no it's not
no no but Charles I thought about that
and I thought that they look close
enough in the sky so that that planet's
orbit would be sufficiently far that it
wouldn't go into a chaotic spiral out of
control I'm gonna tell you right now if
George Lucas were here he would kick you
both in the testes but it was beautiful
and in fact there was an Astrophysical
Journal article written around 2005 or
so called two suns in the sky and that
was an early attempt to do a census of
stars and exoplanets that had a very
very good page no triple stars quadruple
stars yeah they exist their planet you
just have to be orbiting really far away
otherwise as you orbit your
gravitational allegience continually
changes yeah depending on which star
you're closest to at any given point and
that can wreak havoc not only on the
stability of the climate on the planet
you're on but also on its very orbit and
and when an orbit goes unstable it'll
either fall into one of the stars or get
ejected from the solar system entirely
and in facts you do simulations or the
formation of solar systems you can give
a solar system like 40 planets and it'll
settle out over time kicking planets out
eating other plan
down to some stable set of planets we
think our solar system with its eight
planets might have had dope don't even
don't even get me started here so all
I'm saying is it may be oh that there
are more planets rogue moving between
stars than there are in orbit around
stars themselves dejected from the
formation process of solar systems
himself Nomad planets planets without a
solar system what's that
Nomad planets yes planets without us
whole homeless planet homeless play
that's correct
hi I'm Sarah McLaughlin you know where
the rest of the bit goes we don't have
time for it but our our astronomical
technology has gotten to the point one
less one less thing about this place Oh
what know what where we can actually see
these interlopers coming through the
solar system you may have seen the news
at a second
such asteroid like product an
interstellar object they're calling them
is OS coming through the solar system at
a weird angle and we can watch them go
by sometimes even just for a few days
but they certainly exist and so I expect
to see many many more of those as the
years go by and our technology improves
issues and another interesting thing
they could actually possibly have life
because we know on earth earth still has
retained heat from its formation and
their life forms thriving on geo
chemical energy at the bottom of the
ocean where they've never seen a
sunlight on so if you have a rogue
planet that could be an entire biosphere
beneath the surface that cares not a
whit that it isn't orbiting a star you
know that's dope that's tough
that is dough Charles at our next
conference we have to say that's dope
right after I talk about that we're
gonna end that segment and go into our
third segment
give it up New York comic-con
[Applause]
New York comic-con
2019 yes
all right we got to go there Charles
yeah this whole say anywhere but there
yeah it's no we have to explore whatever
science we can find in Star Wars oh okay
so how about but let's let's let's give
it a scientific grounding let's talk
about the planets that they find them on
so there be exoplanets we're looking for
as well as aliens yes they encounter do
you think the famous barsy dude exactly
so what's your judgement of how well
they did the aliens in there um aside
for the fact that almost all of them
have two arms one head and two legs and
one torso they did a pretty good job
they're actors that have to get a page
yeah yeah yeah hard to do otherwise
although with digital technology now
what's-his-face Jabba the Hutt has a
tail right ways like that so yeah
they're doing better and better I think
more and more people are recognizing
that alien life-forms are not limited by
the imagination that we human beings
have the the panoply of life that could
exist is far beyond our own imaginations
to be able to imagine them yeah well I
would make a stronger statement than
that if you look at other life-forms on
earth that's true most of it does not
look humanoid that's if I had two arms
to let earthworms oak trees and octopus
I'd said that right now he's the boy dr.
poore yes uh most life on Earth in the
Star Trek looks less like human Mr Man
then the aliens in the bar scenes of
Salwa that's right well in Star Trek The
Next Generation Star Wars right now oh
sorry but in the season seven episode
the chase okay go in the season seven
episode the chase they sort of tried to
explain why maybe every humanoid species
looks humanoid right there's a species
that predated all of us that see that
see that was there right so that could
software of how unimaginative they're
aliens were right and they backed into
an explanation for it that's in ways
that no one would have ever thought to
do for Star Wars but you know the first
Star Trek the
Dorian's were very clever they did them
well I'm sorry we talked about Star Wars
yes so sorry so so tell me about the
exoplanets that they land on why is it
that no one ever needs a spacesuit when
they land on a planet I think it's
because they're so capable of going at
their purported Lightspeed thing to
anywhere in the galaxy at any arbitrary
speed that they can just find enough
planets that everyone lives perfectly
and they don't have to have spacesuits
so they don't need to go the ones that
need spacesuits for right why would you
yeah there's no point right yeah it's
like you can pick and choose yeah it's
what you're saying right well here's
something that I thought was true and I
later learned wasn't oh that you can
find a planet that has nitrogen action
oxygen atmosphere so you don't need a
thing and you realize no it's not that
planets have this random combinations of
gases and you find the one that you
could survive on we have oxygen in this
atmosphere because we have life yeah so
if you find a place with oxygen given
our current understanding of things it
probably has other life there as well
that's right so it's a great point
that's actually a really good point
right right you're not looking for
planets at random in that regard because
oxygen is chemically unstable so if you
have stable oxygen it means it's
constantly being regenerated the stuff
that pulls out other gifts others get
added to it great point yeah so can you
can you muster any other thing about
Star Wars science well x-wings
they can't fly they just can't Wow Tie
Fighters they can't fly either well what
if the typewriters are moving in the
vacuum why do they need wings at all
well that's the point because they legs
are completely useless in the vacuum of
space yeah but that I I think that what
we're saying seeing in that environment
is that the propulsion systems in Star
Wars have somehow tapped into something
that's not in our galaxy or universe
maybe a force of some kind that we don't
really understand
they allow things that otherwise could
not fly to fly what force that could be
I just don't know it's a I don't want to
force that explanation too much you
don't want to be too forceful about that
so a couple other things if you're
moving through the vacuum your ship will
not bank a turn right that's not how you
turn in a vacuum right and now I'm not
even commenting on all the sounds and
explosions in space yeah that was what
was good it was good I bet you do wookie
really well to now do a wookie banking
through space awesome so Charles what I
think happened there is with the aliens
yeah is that anything that sort of looks
a little different from human is that's
not from Earth it counted as alien for
so many decades in people's imaginations
in science fiction give it a third
eyeball or give it an ant and Tennie or
make it green or look like a gorilla
yeah yeah just just put some other
feature on it which it's intelligent but
clearly not human and that satisfy
people's need for what how different an
alien might look the other nests
what was on the screen well it mattered
not so much sometimes it's a familiarity
of what's on screen I mean when you look
at the abominable snowman that you know
tied Luc up in the snow cave yeah that's
just an abominable snowman that's not
like that's not like you know an alien
we are like seriously that you no longer
the island of misfit toys with a dentist
with Rudolph yeah you know that's a
really good point you know the idea that
aliens and movies have to be different
but not so different as to be
unrelatable to us that's a great see
right if on the ice planet hoth Luke
Skywalker were dangled by some amoeboid
like thing I guess we wouldn't feel so
scared of it right wait wait wait so I
agree with you but I don't
with you so in other words I amaze you
don't agree you're a neutral know what
it what it means is you are right the
alien has to have something you can
relate to otherwise you can't relate to
it like et all right DT even spoke a
little English okay right both you all
scare me sometimes did I tell you that
80 is actually a vegetable
did you know this oh my I can turn
plants yeah well so that the counselor
white has such a good relationship as
well just a plant in the bright someone
said what what can I tell you how I know
this please
okay not just okay Steven Spielberg
visited my office and we talked about
Beatty and I said look the thing is it's
got two arms two legs fingers a head
eyes nose mouth it's human and so
actually he conceived it to be a
vegetable Wow does Steven Spielberg
communicating directly to me I don't
know first-hand knowledge for first-hand
knowledge not here he'd get more
first-hand than that that's right
so but wait would that mean it'd be
moral to eat eat eat so would a
vegetarian eat eat a yeah that's the cat
well he's sentient well I'm gonna tell
you this many years ago there's a
comedian named Paul Mooney I remember
yeah and he used to do a joke he was
like et he better be glad he didn't show
up in the ghetto they would have put him
in a pot of greens and ate his ass we've
gotta end it there join me join me
thinking Charles move
our resident geek in chief Chuck nice
I've been your host Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist and as
always I bid you to let's try this again
and as always I bid you to thank you all
14 of you thank you
if I may take liberties it may I read a
letter to if I may
thank you oh thank you you remembered
yeah
I'm born happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you
happy birthday
[Music]
happy birthday too
thank you I don't know why they plant
Comic Con on my birthday I don't know
how they did that so at the risk of
sounding like it's a shameless plug I
have a book coming out on Tuesday
it's called letters from an
astrophysicist and it contains
correspondence I've had over the years
with the public on all manner of very
personal private things that I just
never talked about on YouTube videos or
on shows such as this and you've never
seen me debate a creationist for example
or UF ologist I'd never they're in here
okay conversations with them in this
book someone else is there at large
hairy ape
wandering the Pacific Northwest I engage
that person in this book three letters
are from prisoners one who's serving
time and he won't be able to watch his
kids grow through their teenage years
wrote to me and said I just learned that
they like science is there any advice
you can give me that I can share with
them to reassure them that I still love
them I mean it's so there's some
heart-wrenching stuff in here
what I want to do is read to you the
epilogue if I may it's very personal but
so the epilogue I know I might
there's some demanding people out there
read it don't do this
Rick okay damn y'all okay I got put on
my old people glasses so hold on I
haven't cuz I'm a I'm an old fart I'm
probably 60% gray and it's all tinted
now cuz it's like yes couple years I'll
come out all grey and I'll be with y'all
I see some great folks out there right
there okay I'm with you okay
by the way Neil we call that hair color
okay all right
epilogue a eulogy
of sorts a letter to dad Saturday
January 21st 2017 based on a eulogy I
delivered to friends and family here in
New York City at the Holy Trinity
Catholic Church dear dad thank you for a
lifetime of wisdom you've bestowed upon
me drawn from moments circumstances and
incidences in your life with your
permission I'll share a few of that
which for me rise above all others I've
never forgotten the story of your high
school gym teacher who highlighted your
body type as one that would not make a
good runner in the track and field unit
of class your reaction nobody's gonna
tell me what I cannot do with my life
you immediately took up running you also
ran in Hitler's Berlin stadium for the
1946 GI Olympics the post-war world was
not ready for a traditional Olympics so
this special event contested soldier
athletes of the various theatres of
conflict around the world and by college
you became world class in middle
distance races
at one time capturing the fifth fastest
time in the world for the 600 yard run
during upon that example for inspiration
I have overcome the most negative
societal forces on my life's ambitions
I've never forgotten the story of your
best friend Johnny Johnson also a track
star competing in a meet against the New
York Athletic Club in the day they of
course admitted only wasps so athletic
Blacks and Jews instead competed as
teammates for the Pioneer Club founded
for that purpose as Johnny came around
the last turn in the quarter-mile he was
a head of the New York Athletic Club
runner by several strides when he
overheard the fellows coach audibly yell
to his runner catch that [ __ ]
Johnnie's reply to himself was simple
and direct this is one [ __ ] he ain't
gonna catch
and lengthened his lead to the finish
line what today might be called
microaggressions back then were parlayed
into forces of inspiration to excel from
that example I've used such occasions in
my life to excel beyond even the
expectations I held for myself
you told of immigrant grandma's work as
its seamstress grandpa's work as a night
watchman for the food service company
horn & Hardart a good thing because he
would occasionally bring home leftover
food when the money was tight your
stories of strife would never
hate-filled
never bitter instead they were hope
filled and inspirational conveyed with
tentative confidence that the arc of
social justice will continue to bend
towards righteousness I carry that
vision for society's future into every
day of my life you studied hard in
school and took your interest in social
justice all the way to your appointment
as mayor Lindsay's Commissioner of New
York City's human resources
administration journalists don't write
articles about news that does not happen
but the program's you enabled in the
inner city empowering the youths during
the powder-keg years of the late 1960s
ensured that any unrest or disturbance
would be mild sure enough
New York was calm compared with what
went down in watts Newark Detroit
Cincinnati Milwaukee and especially in
Chicago Washington DC and Baltimore for
which federal troops were called in to
quell the violence you work behind the
scenes on this with your only reward the
quiet knowledge that the nation's
largest city did not burn during the
most turbulent years of the most
turbulent decade in American history
since the Civil War
striving to do what is right without
regard to who takes notice should be a
model for us all
your stories and perspectives I've got
navigating people politics funding
streams and the legacies of institutions
deeply informed my successful efforts to
create from whole cloth a brand new
Department of astrophysics at the
American Museum of Natural History you
taught me that in life it's not good
enough to be right you also must be
effective for that I now count the
formation of that department as one of
the highest achievements of my
professional career so dad this thank
you is simply public notice of what I
have already thanked you for in life
bestowing upon me guiding principles for
living my life to the fullest and along
the way when possible lessening the
suffering of others I know I will miss
you because I already do Cyril deGrasse
Tyson rest in peace October 19 27
December 2016
so
listen all we love you comic-con there's
nothing like a comic-con community a
comic-con audience where the biggest
fight anyone gets into is whether your
cosplay was authentic and if the world
were run by Comic Con attendees it would
be a peaceful place and we'd have
technology taking us into the future
so yes it will be not who would have
ever thought that the geek said who was
pummeled and bullied in school would
become one of the most strongest
economic forces of the land as well as
the people who everyone else comes to to
fix their computer so I just want to say
the comic-con community is a very
special community I don't want any of
you to forget that surely you won't
thank you for indulging me in this
letter to my father he was 89 so his
death was not tragic but I miss him as
we miss so many loved ones who have
passed but you can tell if you speak of
a loved one you bring them back to life
and this is part of what it is to carry
wisdom insights and love from one
generation to the next
Comicon thank you have a good night
[Applause]
[Music]